hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with the on-call compliance Solutions
and I'm back with another compliance tip
of the week this week we're talking
about steam MC control
si.l2-3.14.6 monitor organizational
systems including inbound and outbound
Communications traffic to detect attacks
and indicators of potential attacks
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
is feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all this cmmc dfars
and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff on
top of an already colossal workload I've
got great news for you if you found your
home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it so in
this control they are really dictating
exactly what needs to be in place with
our firewall and our seam solution the
firewall needs to be there monitoring
traffic both incoming and outgoing but
then we need something that will report
on that which could be either the
firewall or the seam solution the best
solution to solve uh for all of this is
uh and this control is really what you
have your seam solution or your security
information and event management
solution hooked up to your firewall so
those alerts are coming into your system
the same way all the other alerts do for
a single pane of glass approach that is
the ideal way this should really be
solved for ready to see what the
assessors want on this one let's go
all right three things you're looking
for determine if the system is monitored
to detect attacks and indicators of
potential attacks again this is a
demonstrate kind of control so we're
going to basically answer the question
in a written form and say hey look uh
it's implemented via the same solution
and our firewall but we're going to have
to go demonstrate that with an assessor
they're going to have to show them the
settings and show them how those alerts
are coming through next one determine if
uh inbound Communications traffic is
monitored to detect attacks and
indicators of potential attacks uh yes
this is again going to be implemented
via our same solution in firewall again
we're going to demonstrate how uh you
know that traffic is monitored and
detected we're going to show them the
active packet filtering we're going to
show them the antivirus in the firewall
and we're going to show them those seam
alerts coming out of the firewall when
things happen
assessment Point determine if outbound
Communications traffic is monitored to
detect attacks and indicators of
potential attacks again this is
implemented via the same solution and
the firewall same thing we're going to
basically make sure that it's not just
inbound that's protected guys it's got
to be outbound as well very very
important
now if you have no idea what a seam
solution is or you're trying to figure
out how to get this all hooked up and
working with your firewall and you're
just on The Struggle Bus my feelings are
with you okay and the good news is I
went out and did something about it okay
because at on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon so I have more Defense
work with higher profit margins now
that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you first off thank
you thank you for hanging with us for
over I don't know 300 plus videos help
us out with the big thumbs up on that
like button you you know we want you to
hit that subscribe button okay it makes
our day we're super stoked about all the
subscriber growth we're going to keep
kicking button delivering this awesome
content you do your job and hit that
subscribe button and it's the best way
you can get all of the latest compliance
information and content as soon as our
compliance learns roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign
anyway